today's question comes from josephine in
nebraska what a great name
we're on baby step two with about twenty
thousand dollars in debt left to pay off
which will take about 18 months
i had an opportunity to pick up a side
hustle that's in my sweet spot that
would allow us to shave off at least
nine months off baby step two
when i told my husband about this his
first response oh boy
can you even i can't imagine saying this
to our world can you read it can you can
you even read it
his first response was then i'll have to
do everything around the
house so in order to avoid an argument
i'd decline the job
now the same opportunity's been offered
to me again i spoke to him about it and
get the same response
how do i deal with this selfishness two
before
i was gonna say i i think my wife would
stab me in the forehead
with a fork i mean come
on good god what a child what an
immature
i don't know man what a child little boy
yeah i
you're gonna be miserable you'll be
miserable dude until you wake up and
learn how to serve
other people our greatest joy comes
in serving others it is a paradox
right it doesn't sound like it but
you're you're going to be most happy
young man when you learn to serve
and um and by the way this woman is not
gonna
you're gonna be doing everything around
your house in short order my brother
because you're going to be the only one
there buddy the only one there
she's uh or you may not be living
that's yeah one of the two you got a
fork in your you know you've been duct
taped to
something when you're asleep you know oh
my gosh
josephine you got i mean yeah when
you're dealing with someone this
immature
this um unwilling to
to hear your heart on a number of
different things man because this is
bigger than just paying off
this is about it's bigger than housework
yes man this is about you finding
yourself
everything's about him okay uh here's
now all now that we've vented and uh are
mad at the little wuss
um let's how do you actually fix this i
would say
if you're not in a good church and there
are good churches and there are
toxic misses but find a good church
where the people are healthy
mentally spiritually emotionally find an
older couple
and get them involved in your life and
that guy
in that older couple will take your
husband out in the backyard and explain
things to him
explain things don't you think yeah i
mean
or get a good pastor involved or even
get to a marriage counselor not now
junior birdman here is not going to
marriage counseling because he's too
cool for school
but uh you need to go and learn how to
talk to him
about how this is going to end up for
him
because my experience with this stuff
john and i'm not i'm i don't have the
phds and all this other stuff
i've just watched it too often even in
our friends group over the years you
know you go through the stages of
everybody's getting married then
everybody's having kids then everybody's
getting divorced that's right
and so you know and i've done a lot
enough financial
coaching over the 30 years that i see
this
ladies in particular and i don't know
it's not sexist i think it's
um they they boil
until they reach a point and then when
the switch flips
it's off they're done right you can't
get them back
you can't reel it back in guys will kind
of go
out there and then come back and rare
back in right but uh
you know once she flip once her switch
flips
uh junior birdman you're in trouble yeah
because you will have lost her she will
not be you cannot retrace these steps
right
because she will put up with this and i
don't want first i didn't want to or
our argument now she's out saying it out
loud how do i deal with this selfishness
and then if this just continues and he
doesn't get better she's going to have
enough
and there's nobody can talk her out of
it there's no amount of bible teaching
about divorce it's going to work
she's just going to be done because
somebody for the second
time has told her i value you and i'd
like you to come join us
right and somebody in her childhood
didn't tell her that this guy
surely didn't tell her that and this is
bigger than a job this is somebody
saying
hey man i see something valuable in you
so much come join us
and that's what somebody says no to
right that's what somebody says i'm
going to go towards where somebody
values me right
and so josephine you got to have you got
to get somebody else that you can talk
to about this
and because there's bigger stuff here
but at the end of the day you're gonna
have to have
dave you said it i'll say it in a
nerdier way you're gonna have to have
your or what conversation and you gotta
have somebody with some wisdom before
you do that
otherwise you're gonna react and i don't
want it to build up i want you to get
some tools to
let this to by incrementally increase
the heat under him
instead of you just increasing the heat
inside of you and you finally just blow
up and
the switch flips and you're done right
because that's that's what this
i i see this a lot yeah and i don't i
don't
i don't i understand when the switch
flips right when you're dealing with
this type of immaturity i get it
all you can work on
[Laughter]
we got one sentence right and we're
already through with him can't even get
through the dead come
good josephine but yeah man and can you
imagine telling sharon this oh i'm just
trying to think of saying sheila oh oh
oh you don't even want to think about it
what how a hillbilly woman react to that
that would not be good i'm just saying
she would you give you a look that would
say like chapters no my skin would peel
off like indiana jones too
it would just all blow off it would melt
it would melt off your eyes would blow
out of your head
yeah like when they when they touched
the ark of the covenant man
yeah josephine i'm so sorry man yeah and
whoever this guy's
if your wife comes to you and says hey i
i've got an opportunity to help i want
to help too
let your first response be awesome
let's it's going to be some stuff we got
to figure out but let's
figure it out we'll work on this
together it does mean i'm going to have
to pick up all the housework but let's
talk about this yeah you know that's a
one way to answer this is like yeah
i like sitting on my butt in the
recliner
man i'll tell you what oh we do have we
do have a manhood crisis in america
real men know how to serve and vacuum
and vacuum
that's serving i know it's one thing
especially when it's
your dirt in the floor [ __ ] godly dude
i don't do the dishes yes you do they're
yours